okay today I'm going to talk to you
about states of matter we're also going
to have a look at state changes as well
so there are three states we need to
know about three states are solids
liquids and gases now we are going to
have a careful look at the arrangement
of each of these so first of all let's
start with solid as you can see in
solids the particles are really closely
packed together in a regular arrangement
for example in these rows that we can
see right here now a misconception is
that this particles in a solid do not
move they do they all vibrate around a
fixed position so they do move but
they're not free to move wherever they
want they vibrate now if I keep on
adding thermal energy to this solid
eventually we will get a change of state
called melting so melting is when we
change a solid to a liquid when we melt
on a substance some of these strong
forces of attraction are overcome and
the particles are now free to move as
you can see they're still tightly or
pretty close together but not quite as
densely packed together as a solid so
this is what's happening in a liquid the
particles have more energy in their
kinetic stores than particles in a solid
they can move freely and randomly in
different directions now if I was to add
more energy here heat leads up further
eventually I would get a process called
evaporation or evaporating this is the
process of turning a liquid to a gas
again now these we're giving the part
was more and more energy because if I
heat them up the energy is transferred
into particles kinetic energy stores
making them move faster so eventually
have enough energy to overcome their
attraction and then we have a gas form
in these particles move with a lot of
energy randomly in any direction there's
virtually no forces acting between these
particles at all now we
go the other way instead so instead of
adding energy we can remove energy ie
cool a substance down in order to get a
state change the other way so the state
change for a gas to a liquid is called
condensing we're making the particles
have less energy less kinetic energy and
eventually due to their lesser due to
having less movement
we'll start to form attractions between
the different particles so we now go
from a gas to a liquid called condensing
the final state change of these will
major state change is this one here from
a liquid to a solid and that process is
called freezing again we're removing
even more energy so these particles have
less and less kinetic energy so that
after a while the strong attractions
form between the different particles
holding them in these fixed positions so
we now have a solid there's actually one
final state change that we're just going
to show you some substances can go
straight from a solid to a gas or a gas
to a solid and this change is called
sublimating so we just need to make a
couple more notes about the differences
between solids liquids and gases so
we're gonna have a look at the two
extreme so this end of the spectrum with
solids and this end of the spectrum of
gases so in a solid first of all there
are strong forces of attraction this is
what's holding the particles together in
their fixed positions yes they vibrate
but there's strong forces of attraction
where is this end in a gas there's
almost no forces of attraction
attraction between the different
particles they're really spread out and
as a result there's very few forces
whatsoever we can look at the difference
in density so for most substances solids
have a higher density
because the particles are more tightly
packed together then liquids then gases
so at this end would have the lower
density there are exceptions to this but
for most substances this is true
finally let's think about how much
energy each one has in its kinetics Thor
the solids have the least energy in the
kinetics thoughts they have a low amount
of energy in the kinetics store so the
particles do not move around freely they
vibrate around fixed positions whereas
these gas particles here they have lots
of energy in the kinetic store now the
final thing that I want to talk about is
state changes relating to the mast
now despite density density changing
when we melt evaporate condensed freeze
a substance the mass never changes we
don't suddenly have particles lost or
gained so as a result all of these state
change results in the same mass of the
substance so during state changes mass
stays the same so guys hopefully that's
hopefully that's gone through nicely the
diversity in solids liquids and gases
looking at state changes and what that
means in terms of energy and density and
mass thank you